what's going on everybody welcome to
part 4 of our Python with open CV for
image analysis and video analysis
tutorial series in this part we're going
to take talking about is like basic
image operations in the next tutorial
we'll kind of continue building on top
of that for this tutorial again I'm
going to make use of this watch jpg file
again as usual you can use any image you
want so just use whatever you're you
want to use so to start we use the we're
going to need the typical import numpy
is NP and then import c v2 then we're
going to need to bring in the image so B
image equals CV to M read and we're
going to read in that watch that jpg or
whatever the file is that you used and
I'm going to say CV to M read underscore
color so generally with image analysis
the way it's going to work is you've got
your input source whatever that happens
to be and then you're going to start
doing analysis well your input source
most likely unless you specify that you
don't want to be the case generally what
people do is they have their input
source is full color just the original
feed and then immediately they convert
it to grayscale and then they begin to
perform their analysis and all that and
like let's say you're trying to find a
face okay so you perform your analysis
you find your face and you find the
coordinates of that face and then you
actually draw that rectangle you can
draw it on the color on the gray version
but actually you only need to draw it on
the colored version so you draw that a
little rectangle on the colored version
at the coordinates that you know there
is a face and now you've done image
analysis on a color image that's
generally the way it goes so the source
a lot of times is going to remain color
and then you'll immediately convert it
to gray do analysis and then superimpose
your analysis on the gray just on color
so so what we're going to do now to
reference like a specific pixel you can
do it by pixel equals image and in the
location so we'll say 55 by 55 that
would be the location and that would be
the value of this location so
or color values so for example we could
print px like this and that's the actual
color value for that pixel further you
can actually modify that pixel we could
say image 5555 that exact same pixel now
equals 255 255 now that is a white pixel
okay then we could do the exact same
thing we did up here and come down here
did it really go away oh my goodness
okay pixel equals image 5555 print px
don't type oh I'm in typo in a lot today
and now you can see it's actually being
converted to a white pixel now the the
next thing that we want to reference is
this thing called an R oh I'll see
people say ROI of the image what did it
actually this should just say ROI region
or ROI stands for region of image it's
just a sub image of an image basically
so the what we can say is we could say
something like this we can specify a
region of the image so a region of an
image might be something like this like
ROI equals image and then you could say
100 to 150 and then 100 to 150 and then
we could print ROI I believe it will be
an umpire race so it will truncate it
for us sure enough but this is the
entire region of that image all the
pixel values now we can close that and
instead what we can do it's hit the heck
out of and get a little excited smashing
my keyboard over here we can actually
convert from fans to
tivity by 25 to 55 so now that region of
that image will be just a big white
square okay and let's go ahead let's see
what we're looking at now so let's go
ahead CVT IM show and we'll just say
just a left nemesis Mitch
image and as you can see dot wait key
I'll make that same mistake we made
before and see what you that destroy all
windows I say we run that real quick
sure enough you probably can't see it on
my video but you can probably see them
your pics picture that you've got that
one little white pixel subsequently we
have converted that ROI to a big nasty
white square pretty cool now the next
thing that we want to do possibly is
like what we can do is we can take an
ROI and move it like it's almost like a
cut and paste so or a a copy and paste
not a cut and paste so for example what
we could say is on my image the watch
face watch underscore face is close to
I'm going to comment this out so my
kitten much I will leave it there
screw it image and the watch face is
about the 30 37 to 111 and then 107 to
194 and then what we can do is we can
take this region of image if we pull up
a calculator like 111 minus 37 is 74
total pixels and then 194 - 107 is 87 so
keep that in mind we're going to use
those numbers in just a moment watch
face equals this this is a region of an
image and then what we can do is we can
redefine a new region of an image so for
example we could say image and then
remember those numbers before it was
zero to 74 comma zero to 87 that's our
region of image and that is going to be
equal to watch underscore face make sure
this has to be the same size if it's not
the same size it's not going to work out
well in your favor so let's go ahead and
save and run that now and sure enough as
you can see in my image and probably
your image the watch face has been
basically copy and pasted over here into
the corner
so you can reference regions of images
that won't be the last time you see that
so going to store that to memory now
those are just some really simple
operations in the next tutorial we're
going to be covering a little bit more
complex operations that we can apply to
our images that we're going to pretty
much be seeing throughout the entire
series especially one of them or at
least one of the concepts so if you have
questions comments concerns whatever up
to this point feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the sport
subscriptions until next time